hi all lucy here with a fresh pot of
gamespot news for you now we all know
how to keep new tech safe and sound
maybe keep those screen protectors on
get a fancy case anything to keep it
looking fresh well it appears that for
the new iphone 6 it might not be that
easy yes it turns out that the brand new
iphone 6 plus can be completely bent out
of shape by hand pressure alone early
apple adopters have taken to posting
pictures of their angular new phones on
tech blogs and on twitter complaining
that simply storing the phone in their
pockets has damaged it could it be hacks
could it be people just not taking care
of their new purchases not so as this
video by unboxing therapy shows that you
don't have to have the hand strength of
andre the giant to reshape the device
the back of the phone features a
six-inch aluminium casing which appears
to be the part of the phone that's not
resisting the pressure apple sold more
than 10 million iphone 6s and 6 pluses
in the space of three days the
corporation has yet to respond to claims
of bent hardware presumably they're all
still trying to recover from tv truck
schedule gate of course there's already
the hashtag bendgate and a novelty
twitter account so what tech have you
successfully bent will the iphone 6 plus
blend for all the latest tech hiccups
stay tuned here